Transcription: Matt Leedham
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Qu’est-ce que je fais là ?
La question mérite d'être posée.
La personne que vous avez devant vous,
c’est quelqu’un qui coche
les cases de la réussite
telle qu’on la conçoit en France.
Un bon diplôme, le nom
de grandes entreprises sur mon CV.
Et pour couronner le tout,
bientôt, une petite conférence TEDx
à ajouter à mon palmarès.
Ça, c'est la face émergée de l'iceberg.
Ce qu’on ne voit pas,
c’est comment j’en suis arrivée là.
Et vu ce que je suis et là d’où je viens,
il était peu probable
que je monte un jour sur cette scène.
Ce qu’on ne voit pas,
c’est que j’ai grandi
dans une petite ville de Normandie,
que je suis issue d’un milieu ouvrier,
que mes parents n’ont pas fait d’études.
Et en plus de ça, on m’a diagnostiqué
une forme d’autisme
qu’on appelle encore parfois
l’autisme Asperger.
Un syndrome qui ne me prédisposait pas,
mais alors pas du tout,
à la prise de parole en public.
En voyant mon parcours, on pourrait
se dire que j’ai beaucoup de mérite
car j’ai dû fournir
plus d’efforts que la moyenne
pour franchir chaque étape,
voire que je ne dois
ma réussite qu’à moi-même,
que je n’ai pas compter sur l’appui
d’un milieu social privilégié.
Des parcours comme le mien suscitent
souvent l’admiration, l’espoir,
l’envie de croire
qu’il  est possible de réussir
même quand tout nous prédestine
à rester là où nous sommes.
Cette vision des choses,
portée par la croyance dans le mérite,
est rassurante.
Elle nous dit qu’avec du talent
et de l’effort, on peut tout accomplir.
Elle nous dit
que quand on veut, on peut.
Elle nous donne l’impression d’avoir
le contrôle total sur notre vie
et qu’on peut tendre la réalité
par  la seule force de notre volonté.
Ça, c'est la belle histoire
qu'on a envie de raconter.
Malheureusement, les choses
ne se passent pas tout à fait comme ça.
Cette phrase,
“Quand on veut, on peut”.
D’accord, mais ceux qui n’ont pas pu,
ils n’ont pas voulu, alors ?
Par exemple, comment expliquer
qu’en France, il faut six générations
pour qu’une personne issue
d’une famille pauvre
accède au revenu moyen ?
Six générations c’est un peu loin, c’est
180 ans, soit près de deux siècles.
Alors qu’est-ce que ça vient
nous dire, cet adage ?
Quand on veut, on peut.
Qu’est-ce que ça vient nous dire
sur ces laissés-pour-compte
de la réussite,
ils ont voulu rester là où ils sont ?
Probablement pas.
Alors, qu’est-ce qu’on fait
de ce constat ?
Comment on pourrait résorber
ces inégalités ?
Souvent, on me répond que c’est
l’éducation qui apportera la solution.
L’ambition de l’école,
la noble ambition de l’école,
est d’oeuvrer pour que chaque jeune
puisse exploiter son potentiel
et réussir quels que soient son genre,
ses origines, sa religion.
Présentée comme le symbole
de la méritocratie,
l'École est considérée comme l'ascenseur
social par excellence.
Elle est censée permettre à chacun
de s’élever dans la société
grâce à ses talents et à ses efforts.
Et moi, je peux l’affirmer
sans hésitation.
Oui, l’École m’a permis de m’extraire
de mon milieu.
J’ai vite compris qu’elle serait le moyen
de créer les conditions de ma liberté,
de choisir ma vie et non pas la subir.
Grâce à mon assiduité, ma persévérance,
je peux intégrer
les meilleures formations:
une prépa littéraire,
un master sélectif à l’université,
et enfin une grande école de commerce.
Si on s’arrêtait là,
on pourrait dire que l’éducation,
l’école,
est capable de résoudre les inégalités
d’un coup de baguette magique.
Et je dois dire que moi aussi, j'y ai cru.
J’ai cru que j’étais le pur produit
d’une société qui récompense le mérite.
Mais mon cas personnel ne doit pas venir
masquer une réalité qui est tout autre.
Les chiffres parlent d’eux-mêmes.
Si je vise l’ENA et que mon père
est lui même un énarque,
mes chances d’intégrer l’école
sont multipliées par 330.
Je vous l'avais dit.
Les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes.
Les inégalités ne s’arrêtent pas
aux grilles de l’école, loin de là.
En fait, l’investissement des parents dans
l’avenir de leurs enfants via l’éducation
est devenu l’une des principales formes
de transmission de privilèges.
J’irais même plus loin en disant
que l’école fonctionne
comme  une machine
de reproduction des élites.
Notamment parce que les formations
les plus prestigieuses
sanctionnent les connaissances
qui correspondent aux codes
des classes sociales plus élevées.
Si vous êtes issu d’une famille
à fort capital culturel,
vous serez plus branché Nietzsche
que Niska, plus TSF Jazz que TPMP.
Et les grandes écoles,
en particulier celles qui incluent
des épreuves de culture générale
comme Sciences-Po
et certaines écoles de commerce,
bien évaluaient implicitement
la maîtrise de ses codes sociaux
et notamment si elles ont
des épreuves orales
qui en plus vont venir juger la façon
de parler des candidats,
leur langage corporel, etc.
Les filières scientifiques
ne sont pas épargnées non plus.
Si les enfants d’ouvriers représentent
près de 30% des jeunes de 18 à 23 ans,
ils sont à peine 1%
sur les bancs de Polytechnique.
Et je peux en témoigner.
Plus j’avançais dans les études,
moins j’étais entourée de personnes
issues du même milieu que moi.
L'écrémage social avait fait son œuvre
et ça s'explique assez facilement.
Les parents aisés ont souvent eux-mêmes
bénéficié de la meilleure éducation.
Ils sont mieux armés pour accompagner
leur enfant dans sa scolarité.
Ils connaissent les filières
d’orientation,
ils peuvent payer des cours particuliers,
des prépas privées,
envoyer leur enfant
en séjour linguistique.
Bref, ils investissent
dans l’avenir de leur enfant
pour qu’ils aient toutes les chances
d’obtenir le meilleur diplôme,
la voie royale en France
pour atteindre les positions
les plus élevées dans la société.
Cet avantage de naissance,
on peut le pallier
grâce à un dispositif
d’égalité des chances.
Dans mon cas, j’avais
de bonnes notes à l’école,
mais il me manquait l’impulsion
pour prendre confiance en moi
et dans ma capacité à faire des études.
Notamment parce que j’avais pas
de modèle à suivre dans mon entourage.
J’ai pu bénéficier de l’accompagnement
d’un mentor.
J’ai aussi intégré une prépa
dédiée aux boursiers
pour préparer les admissions parallèles
des écoles de commerce.
Toutes ces initiatives permettent
de rétablir un équilibre
entre ceux qui sont bien nés et ceux
qui sont défavorisés, voire discriminés.
Là encore, on pourrait s’arrêter là.
Certes, tous les élèves
n’ont pas les mêmes atouts
selon leur milieu d’origine,
mais si on leur donne
les mêmes chances au départ,
ce sont déjà les meilleurs
qui gagneront la course
en fonction de leur talent
et leur acharnement.
Oui, mais voilà, un système juste
d’égalité des chances ne produirait pas
une société juste pour autant.
Car on aurait toujours des gagnants
d’un côté et les perdants de l’autre.
Et ceux qu’on désigne comme les gagnants,
ce sont ceux qui possèdent les talents
que valorise la société à un instant T.
Et ça, c'est quand même très aléatoire.
Prenez Lionel Messi.
Si Messi était né au Moyen Âge,
il n’aurait pas rencontré un tel succès
malgré ses talents de footballeur.
Il a eu la chance de naître au XXᵉ siècle
dans un pays qui encourage
la pratique du foot.
S'il était né au Venezuela, on aime
plutôt le basket et le baseball.
Peut-être que sa carrière
aurait été moins impressionnante.
On peut tirer deux conclusions
de cet exemple.
La première, c’est que quand on réussit,
on fait coïncider ses capacités,
son talent, avec ce qu’attend, recherche,
récompense la société.
Plus spécifiquement, le marché
vous conduit dans une société capitaliste,
certains talents sont très recherchés
par le marché et d’autres pas du tout.
Et à ça s’ajoute un facteur
temporel parce que,
avec les innovations technologiques,
les talents recherchés aujourd’hui
ne le seront peut-être plus demain.
Et enfin, il y a des talents qui ont été
peu valorisés de tout temps.
Savoir lécher son coude, par exemple.
Ça, c'est la première chose.
La deuxième chose,
peut-être la plus simple,
mais aussi la plus vertigineuse.
Même si j’ai le talent que recherche,
cultive et récompense la société,
le succès que me promet
la méritocratie est loin d’être garanti.
Prenons le cas des sciences.
Dans les sciences, on peut mesurer
la réussite en nombre de publications.
Eh bien cette réussite
est une distribution de Pareto.
C’est à dire que 20% des chercheurs
publient 80% des articles.
Dans les arts, c’est la même chose:
20% des artistes dans un domaine donné
captent 80% des revenus.
Cela montre que
le talent n’est pas récompensé
de manière proportionnelle.
De petits écarts de talent peuvent aboutir
à d’énormes écarts de succès à l’arrivée
et les vainqueurs raflent toute la mise.
En ce sens, la méritocratie n’existe pas.
Puisque de petites différences
deviennent de grandes distinctions,
en créant un fossé gigantesque
entre ceux qui réussissent
et ceux qui passent à la trappe.
Et on préfère admirer
une victoire personnelle
plutôt qu’admettre que parfois,
le succès est le fruit
d’un heureux concours de circonstances
avec son lot d’imprévus et de hasards.
Par exemple, si Hugo m’avait pas contacté
pour me proposer de soumettre
un sujet à ce TEDx,
je ne serais pas là
devant vous aujourd’hui.
En réalité, il est très difficile
de savoir
quel rôle jouent nos efforts personnels
dans nos réussites et nos échecs.
Il y a toujours cette part de chance
ou du moins de circonstances
indépendantes de notre volonté.
Rencontrer la bonne personne
au bon moment.
Tomber sur le sujet qu'on maîtrise
le jour de l'examen.
Et ça, c'est impossible à mesurer,
impossible à quantifier.
Or, quand on a réussi,
on est quand même très tenté
de céder à l’autosatisfaction.
On flatte son ego, on se dit
qu’on a bien travaillé,
que son succès est le fruit
de sa ténacité, son travail,
son acharnement.
Pire encore,
la croyance dans le mérite
nous conduit non seulement
à nous illusionner sur nous-mêmes,
en nous faisant exagérer
la part de notre responsabilité
dans notre propre succès,
mais elle nous pousse aussi à nous
comparer aux autres pour les juger.
Et c'est sans doute ce qui est le plus
gênant dans le concept de méritocratie.
Plus on pense qu’on est responsable
de son propre succès
et qu’on ne doit rien à personne,
moins on se soucie de ceux qui ont échoué,
on se convainc qu’il y a
des gens qui réussissent
et des gens qui ne sont rien.
Et qu’on est bel et bien
à la place qui nous revient,
à la place qu’on mérite.
Dans une société qui encourage
la croyance dans le mérite,
les gagnants sont pleins d’orgueil
et les perdants sont humiliés.
Alors je pose la question:
est-ce vraiment la société
que nous voulons ?
On arrive à la partie
plus optimiste de cette histoire,
car je veux nourrir l’espoir
qu’un autre modèle est possible.
Avec une pensée émue pour celles et ceux
qui sont considérés comme des gens nuls.
Je pense à mes parents qui n’ont pas eu
ma chance et n’ont pas pu faire d’études.
Je pense à ce qu’ils ressentent
en apprenant qu’ils n’ont pas coché
les cases de la réussite
malgré tout leur talent.
Mes parents ont eu mille et un métiers
et en plus, c’est des vrais MacGyver.
Ils savent réparer, fabriquer des objets,
retaper une maison du sol au plafond.
Alors que moi, ma seule réalisation,
c’est d’avoir pu monter
une armoire en kit.
Et en plus, elle est bancale.
Pourtant, c'est moi qu'on invite à venir
parler de mon parcours, de mon mérite,
alors que mes parents du mérite,
ils en ont autant que moi.
Ce que je veux dire par là,
c’est que chaque personne possède
un talent qui lui est propre
comme un petit bijou cousu
à l’intérieur de son manteau.
Ce bijou, ce joyau,
il n’est pas forcément visible des autres.
Parfois, la personne elle-même
ne voit pas,
mais il est bien là,
caché dans la doublure.
On devrait permettre à chaque personne
de le faire briller,
de cultiver son talent
et d’être reconnu et digne
là où il est, tel qu’il est.
Et ça commence dès l'école.
L’École pourrait
développer les aptitudes de chaque élève
sans chercher à hiérarchiser
les compétences
et les filières entre elles.
Elle pourrait accompagner chaque enfant
dans la voie de son épanouissement
pour qu’il ou elle puisse choisir sa vie
sans émettre de jugement de valeur.
Et quand on est du bon côté,
celui des gagnants,
ça passe par la nécessité de reconnaître
que vivre dans une société
qui valorise nos talents est une chance,
pas un dû.
Notre réussite tient aussi
à des rencontres
et des personnes déterminantes :
nos parents, nos professeurs,
quelqu’un qui a cru en nous.
Et si on admet que notre succès
est le fruit de nos efforts, bien sûr,
et aussi du soutien de notre entourage,
parfois de la chance d’être bien nés,
ou d’avoir été au bon endroit
au bon moment.
Alors on peut commencer à montrer
plus de compassion
envers ceux qui ont moins réussi
parce qu’on aurait très bien pu
se retrouver à leur place
si on avait été moins chanceux.
Si on adhérait à cette vision,
on emploierait plus volontiers
notre temps,
notre énergie, notre réseau
à faire de la place à d’autres.
Pour qu’enfin cesse cette idée absurde
que la vie est une course,
une compétition qui couronne une poignée
de gagnants et dénigre les perdants.
Cette notion d’interdépendance,
le fait que d’autres ont contribué
à ma réussite,
invite à une relecture
de la responsabilité individuelle
plutôt que m’accrocher à l’idée
que je suis responsable de mon succès,
et demande gargariser,
je prends conscience du pouvoir
dont je dispose
pour contribuer à la réussite
d’autres personnes.
Je rends ce qui m’a été donné.
J’exprime ma gratitude
envers ceux qui m’ont élevée,
éduquée, encouragée, soutenue,
à ceux qui m’ont donné ma chance,
et à ceux qui m’ont aidé à la provoquer.
Je trouve cette perspective
plus généreuse et encourageante
que l’idéal méritocratique.
Elle permet de cultiver
l’humilité et l’empathie
en vue de dessiner l’ébauche
d’une société plus juste et solidaire
dont nous avons désespérément besoin
pour affronter les défis
qui nous attendent.
Merci.
(Applaudissements.)